we have big breaking news from Capitol
Hill tonight on two fronts former FBI
director Andrew McCabe is reportedly
asking for immunity before he offers
testimony to the Senate Judiciary
Committee Judiciary Chairman Chuck
Grassley wants McCabe former FBI Chief
Jim Comey and former attorney general
Loretta Lynch to testify when the IG
report on the Hillary Clinton email
investigation is finally released
on a separate front Fox News chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Catherine Herridge is reporting this a
lawmaker telling her that FBI
espionage Chief Bill pre-snap who
oversaw the Russia and Clinton probes
has been very cooperative with
congressional investigators pre-snap was
also the supervisor of FBI agent Peter
struck who bashed president Trump of
course remember in several texts the
source says that struck played an even
larger role than we thought initially in
the Clinton email probe and the Russia
investigations let's discuss all of this
now with congressman Ron De Santis
a member of the House and Judiciary
Committees House Oversight and Judiciary
Committee's Democratic strategist
Richard Goodstein and former Deputy
Assistant Attorney General Robert
Driscoll gentlemen it's great to see all
of you big breaking news tonight
congressman DeSantis where do we begin
let's start with this immunity plea for
McCabe every time you hear someone who's
like connected with Trump's it might
want immunity it's like oh my god do you
want immunity you must be guilty but
what's going on here
well look I mean James Comey sent Andrew
McCabe stood tall was just this model
leader and now he wants immunity because
he knows he's in jeopardy with his
conduct over this investigation both the
Clinton and the Trump investigation I
would not give him immunity I would make
him go if he's gonna plead the fifth
amendment then he should plead the fifth
amendment but the idea that he should
get some type of get-out-of-jail-free
card for this is not something I think
the American people would want to see
Richard so the president said in tweets
about McCabe lied lied lied he he
personally called
McCabe's wife a loser right classy
we have very limited time I want to keep
this focus and buy the place I'm the
former Deputy Attorney General
wanting immunity if he has nothing to
hide if he was above board if he had
permission to release information to the
media why is he asking for immunity when
the president asks for the Fifth
Amendment please what you just said
bring that back look the reason is what
is the president asked you for the Fifth
Amendment well everybody seems to
suggest that might be enough look here's
the answer everybody if you've got a
president who issues pardons willy-nilly
has no qualms about asking the Justice
Department go after somebody so McCabe
would be out of his mind not to seek
immunity when you've got somebody at the
top of the basically who his own lawyer
as saying he's concerned about his
climbing he should be concerned when you
got the president going after people
like crazy right this is a criminal
referral though that was made by the
inspector general I mean the Inspector
General laid the predicate for this did
he not Richard I mean I get it that you
don't like Trump I get it that's fine
there's a big nation I'm glad we have
all opinions on the show but this is
someone who in a non-partisan consummate
professional Inspector General called
his credibility right and his is his
basically said he was prevaricated to
put it very kindly in dealing with the
media and now he's been asked to testify
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
Robert you can chime in you get a lot of
experience on this and he wants immunity
I mean that's not the first time
someone's asked for immunity
but this is a wild series of
developments we've had with a former
deputy FBI director well it's smart move
by his lawyer because if he gets
immunity from judiciary then he's free
from prosecution by DOJ and so you'd
rather have a day of embarrassment
before committee then you know do time
but I think it's it's always a trade-off
between transparency and justice when
congressional committees in DOJ are
deciding whether or not to grant
immunity I mean the benefit to immunity
would be he would testify on national TV
with no ability to plead the fifth we
have to say everything he knows and
every won't hear it
and I think chairman Grassley would have
to weigh that against waiting to see
what happens in the DOJ prosecution
which will take additional months I
think also does he have evidence I mean
there's at least some reports suggesting
that he may have
affirmative evidence and Comey did know
about this leak that he mccabe has
gotten nailed for Comey said no he
didn't authorize that so if he was
producing something like that that may
be one reason he always backs up call me
right he's always backs up call me I
think but before when the Trump Trump
conversation with with Comey at the
White House and he basically yeah well
Comey basically said to me what he put
in his memo to the file so they were on
the leak he said Comey approved it and
Comey said he didn't approve it so
they're in direct contradiction on that
so they've they've diverged let's move
on to the IG report then we want to go
back to another struck issue this IG
report the president obviously very
frustrated again I wouldn't be tweeting
about why it's delayed but that's you
know the president so he's gonna tweet
as he sees the president is gonna tweet
but on the issue of the IG report why do
you think this is delay we keep hearing
it's gonna be out any day that's the
problem or like we have a bureaucracy
that is just not accountable to anybody
so we had all these major problems and
the Democrats are actually the ones that
wanted this report initially so in order
to break hold people accountable if it
takes a year and a half to conduct an
investigation then it's just not the way
it's going so I'd say that just a time
what's the point like you know you need
a speedy trial you need a speedy
resolution and then 500 pages how are
Robert Driscoll I want to get back to
Richard to but Robert could the McCabe
request for immunity right have some
relevance here in this delay in the
inspector general report yeah I think
people are overblown the delay I mean
I've represented people in the situation
when the reports done everybody who
represents someone who's been
interviewed in that report gets their
little chunk of the report that mentions
their client gets to review it alone in
a room and not take it with them and has
about a week to get back with any
comments to the IG who then decides
whether or not to take them into account
or not so the fact that it's two weeks
after it's done is about on time I mean
I'd be concerned if it took another week
or so but right about now is about when
it should be coming out in my experience
from when the report is done to when you
work through that process and in this
circumstance there's a lot of
high-powered lawyers involved I'm sure
people are billing lots of hours making
objections
hopefully I say something in support of
the congressman yes I also want this
report to come out as soon as possible
but I think I have different reasons one
I think we're going to hear what
Giuliani was getting in the way of
information from the Southern District
from FBI agents which allowed him to
basically say before it happened that
the second Comey letter was going to
come out secondly I think what we're
gonna see is that Comey yes acted
inappropriately but in ways that helped
the Trump campaign he sat on information
about the Russian investigation about
the Trump campaign and was way out there
in ways that way went over the route you
know broke the rules both in July and in
October by what he said about the
Hillary email investigation so I'm with
you I I agree I hope it comes out
tomorrow what do you guys make of this
new text was not a new text as an
unredacted text and this is a text
between Peter struck and Lisa page now
we learn this today because this was
released as part of the 500 pages of
text released by the Senate today and
here's what this looks like it says
you'll get our oak cou and yes lures
approved and just so you know what that
lures his FBI lingo for spies so the
question tonight were these potentially
sent the spies potentially sent in to
target the Trump campaign going back to
December of 2015 and if so that could be
fairly explosive couldn't not
congressman because Jim Comey said this
investigation began in July July 31st to
be exact of 2016 that text again we'll
learn morning of the house is kind of
not exactly where the Senate is on this
but when you read that text it certainly
appears that they were looking to put
more lures into the campaign in 2015
several people are reporting this
tonight we'll learn more I believe but
what do we what do we think about that
well that was why did they redact that
war exactly that was that was initially
oops it says lures their lures again
lingo the question is why would that
have been redacted is that referring I
mean oak onus obviously is a foreign
potentially foreign spy but I think this
idea that crossfire hurricane started
this on July 31st clearly that's not
true because you had Comey you had
mccabe and lynch deciding not to brief
trump in april when they were supposedly
concerned about carter page you had
Stephane halper
reaching out to the campaign before then
so this did not just start on the 31st
has to follow me 27 and I think I think
he is he I think he's has exposure as a
result of that testimony so you're
saying I don't think he was telling the
truth there no I don't think that's true
and what he have there any way he
wouldn't have known if this is true that
it started earlier perhaps in May when
now bill pre-snap there's another
question he stopped traveled to Lyon the
great step is he's the head of
counterintelligence Peter struck was his
number two now pre step basically has
said struck was really the main guy in
both the Hillary and the the Russia
collusion investigations obviously he
wanted Hillary present he hated Trump
with a passion but pre step himself
traveled to London in May of 2016 that
was again two months before crossfire
her started and again I'm gonna disagree
with the congressman a little bit here
what's twisted about this is that at the
end of the day what struck in the struck
remember drafted the Comey letter ten
days before the election it was his idea
to kind of put that out there he's also
said bad things about Bernie about
Chelsea about holder in addition to
Trump the same things that Marco Rubio
and Ted Cruz were saying during the
campaign the fact is that the FBI when
you look back helped Trump by sitting on
the information about him and hurt
Hillary by breaking the rules and
putting everything out there the reason
why they put the letter I was
embarrassing was to protect their own
behind struck wanted to protect his
behind and commis behind that's why they
did it
well you're right in July she should not
have come out and done that but once he
came out and gave the press conference
he kind of had to do the letter I think
the letter actually the text I mean
again we're gonna learn more but they
redacted the word lawyers again lingo
for spies FBI is not supposed to use the
word spies but they use that word
non-contiguous informants so oak onus
was there that acronym and then lures
was redacted
unredacted now you see what it was
saying right that's again you get all
our lures approved I love the little
smiley face couldn't they have used an
actual emoji they had used that and in
in you know it goes on well I think so
much of this has to do
the time line is the most damaging thing
for people here because people using a
bureaucratic term when they say an
investigation wasn't opened well that
means nothing if there was investigative
activity going on before the
investigation was opened so even the FBI
said well some of these contacts from
our informants you know / spies occurred
you know leading up to the investigation
well there's got to be a point you know
it's kind of like you know did God
create the earth you know who craved
that who created that who created well
somebody has to approve remember this
thing was supposed to have been begun
kind of started sort of when that list
of Trump foreign policy advisors
national security advisors came out and
Carter Page George papadopolis his their
names were on it in this in the spring
of 2016 right but now if this goes back
to 2015 again if it's him
what were they worried about I mean I
mean the stroke they were petrified of
Trump who knows maybe they thought Trump
was gonna catch on and one of the maybe
one of the later struck page text in the
fall was POTUS wants to know everything
we're doing so what did Obama know about
this and when was he briefed on this I
don't think he was in the dark about
this the whole time at all I think Obama
knew exactly what was can we just
remember that we've had whole segments
on shows like this about the struck
secret society about the struck lost
emails so let's try to figure out
exactly yeah I agree we need to get to
the bottom of this but to kind of you
know I agree with you but those are
technical acronyms that are used within
the bureau those aren't like love love
messages between the two of these I mean
all those sure people are fascinated by
those two but those those are technical
terms so it seems like did you get
approval for these lures right and
waiting for the answer but there were no
spies there was one guy who basically
made a couple approaches to people that
had been targeted by the CIA and the FBI
we know that it wasn't just carter page
now the report came out daily a Daily
Caller foundation that also Stephen
Miller was invited to that same event a
da polis and then they reached out to
Sam Clovis and so and here's a thing in
the New York Times when they're their
big article they said at least one
person so there is the paw
ability that there was more than just
Stefan Halper who was trying to initiate
July 2016 the event at University of
Cambridge it looks like they were trying
to get all the nationalists like Miller
I mean you like Russia you come over
here on Steven Miller is really a
Russian plant but again the timeline is
important because we don't have
documents do we we don't have that we
don't have a lot of documents FBI dog
refusing to produce the document I'm
period before July 31st that's why
you're you're gradually getting the text
remember when we we heard from
Papadopoulos and others that the
Russians were trying to get dirt on
Hillary not one person in the Trump
campaign went to the US authorities not
one that's a little bad that's a bad
back I mean do you think this
Papadopoulos I mean this whole this
character is just like he's trolling
bars in London it's like I'm gonna go
back to Trump Tower and I'm gonna be the
cool guy cuz they're gonna be saying I'm
gonna set up a meeting with Trump I mean
he's like the worst person having a
campaign come on but Alexander Downer
murder recently an interview he said I
never even heard about emails I heard
dirt I didn't hear email that was
Australian ambassador that's right I
think we have to have like the you know
the deck of cards and Iraq where you
have them to the X every all faces with
every title guys fantastic as always